there's been a unanimous conclusion by
all the american intelligence services
that russia
tried to monkey wrench the 2016 election
to help
elect trump are you saying that russia
is still a bigger enemy to u.s than
china is today
why didn't donald trump pay taxes i'm a
new yorker i've known this guy since his
70s he's a con man
whether you like the way he lives his
personal life i mean if you think that
never happened you're a fool
all right we'll stipulate that donald
trump is not a saint go on this guy's a
billionaire
he parties they love him he's great he's
always on tv letterman leno
why the hell would you run for office
and ruin your life he's a wrecking ball
he was trying to build a luxury hotel in
partnership with the soviet government
we still have to have a bet so how about
we make the bet on the presidency are
you confident enough to make it biden
trump i'm not happy about it
but i'm going to vote for biden our
democracy is in trouble my friend it's
under attack it's under attack by the
russians and it's under attack by the
president of the united states
[Music]
my guest today won the 1988 pulitzer
prize for national reporting as an
investigative reporter at the
philadelphia inquirer on black budget
spending at the pentagon
and the cia he's a graduate from uh
school of journalism at columbia
university he's written many different
books
legacy of ashes the history of the cia
enemies of history the fbi
one man against the world the tragedy
richard nixon
and his recent book the foley and the
glory
america russia and the political warfare
1945 to 2020
my guest today team tim weiner tim thank
you so much for being a guest on
valuetainment
okay so tim some of us wake up in the
morning
and we want to follow stats on the nba
to find out who had a good game
yesterday in baseball
some want to read a comic book someone
on netflix and chill
someone read a nomad romance novel why
are you so obsessed with studying the ci
and the fbi well i'll tell you uh
when i was a younger reporter way back
in the 20th century
uh i became very interested in uh
what was going on in the reagan
administration
they were selling weapons
to the iranian revolutionary guard
skimming the prophets
and giving them to the anti-communist
guerrillas in central america and uh
people got in a lot of trouble for that
including the president of the united
states so i wanted to know how did
the secret operations of the government
work
the biggest secret operation of the time
1987 was the cia was sending
hundreds of millions of dollars of
weapons to the afghan mujahideen the
holy warriors
in afghanistan who were fighting the
soviet army
who had occupied afghanistan at the end
of 1979.
so reporters didn't go to afghanistan
not with the mujahideen
maybe they'd fly in with the red army in
the kabul
uh but they didn't go into the side of
the afghan rebels i said well i'm young
i wasn't married then didn't have any
kids then i said i'm going to do that
so before i went off to afghanistan i
called up the cia
that was running this huge covert
operation so huge that
you know it was hard to conceal it was
like trying to hide an
elephant with a handkerchief so uh i
called up the public
information officer at the cia that is a
guy
there is a public information officer
at our most secret intelligence agency
the cia
and i said hey uh i'm going off to
afghanistan and you guys
often do country briefings for
journalists who are going up to strange
countries
how about a briefing on afghanistan and
he told me to stick it where the sun
don't shine
so off i went to afghanistan
why would they want to talk about a
secret operation right
so i went to afghanistan for three
months
i saw a stinger missile fired at a mig
soviet mig i saw the brave mujahideen
fighting the red army
i saw them fight and die and i came back
to washington
and i hadn't been back at my desk for
more than a day and the phone rang
guess who same person that's that guy
from the ci and now he's really friendly
hey
tim how you doing how'd you like to come
in for that briefing now
so i walk in i get invited to see i
headquarters
seven miles up the potomac river from
washington
out in the woods and i go through
checkpoint one checkpoint two checkpoint
three
into the headquarters of the cia and i
look up
on the left-hand wall and they're
inscribed in really big gold letters
from the gospel of john it says and ye
shall know the truth
and the truth will make you free well
i'm hooked at that point
i decided that i was going to cover the
cia like other reporters
covered the cops or the courts
and that's what i've done for most of
the rest of my life since then tim let
me ask you did they ever try to recruit
you they did
see i ever said well if a guy like this
you have the courage to go out there and
do this what if we come recruit you
no you know that's a nice fantasy but no
it never happened that way you know
people
don't really understand what the ci is
what the cia does
they think it's either you know james
bond flies into a foreign capital makes
love to a beautiful woman
has two martinis overthrows the
government leaves on the midnight plane
yeah that's really not the way it works
um it's a dirty difficult dangerous
business and people get burned and
sometimes lives are at stake sometimes
the fate of nations is at stake
you know from your own personal history
your family history
that the cia decided it would be a good
idea to overthrow
the freely elected leader of iran in
and put the shah on the peacock throne
the shah was a great friend of the
united states
bought hundreds of millions of dollars
billions of dollars of our weapons
uh but the consequence of that 25 years
later
was the rise of the ayatollahs and the
fall of the shot
and here we are today 40 years later so
the folly in the glory my new book is
about america
russia and political warfare from 1945
to 2020. people think the cold war was
one thing
and the cold war has been over for 30
years and now it's now but no
there's a through line from the end of
world war ii to this present moment
and these two nations america and russia
have been at war with each other
but it's political warfare it's
the way you go to war without
nuclear weapons smart bombs or sending
in the marines
we couldn't go to war that way because
if we did our nations would be reduced
to smoking radiating ruins in a matter
of two hours
so we had to go to war with espionage
sabotage subversion secret operations
and that struggle never ended it didn't
end when the cold war was over
you can see it right now today because
vladimir putin
is running a multitude of covert
operations trying to damage our
democracy
pick up paper turn on the news see it
happening every day
he ran probably the most brilliant
covert operation
since the trojan horse back in the last
election
rubbing salt in our wounds deepening our
divisions
disinformation propaganda fake news
and he's doing it again right now the
difference is
he's got the president of the united
states and they're doing the same thing
and our intelligence services are on red
alert
because if putin succeeds it could be
the death of american democracy
that is what this book is ultimately
about so
you're somebody that has done research
for decades i think that's a fair
assessment to make you've been in this
world for a while uh
35 years how many years 35.
that that is a long time which means
you've been reading up on this pretty
much every article and any article that
has to do with this topic
i'm doing my own reporting in my own
travel and my own research
that's right so so the question i would
have for you uh for somebody that you
know
is running a business i'm i'm uh running
a couple businesses myself and the
audience is a business
a lot in in the world of business sure
we hear for the longest time the enemy
was
russia right even in rocky iv it's
drago going against you know rocky and
you know
everybody's looking around the world my
mother's side they're from baku
azerbaijan you know they're from russia
so armenians who escaped the armenian
genocide come to you around my dad's
assyria and i lived in iran 10 years
so we all saw russia as the big enemy
but from my perspective and what i see
and i'm curious to know what you think
about this
it seems to me that that position of
enemy of the state or any
enemy of the world today has been
you know russia's been dethroned today
by china it seems to me that even on the
left and the right
what they both agree on they don't agree
on a lot you saw the debate the other
day they don't agree on a lot but
if there's one thing they both agree on
the fact that neither side trusts
china um more than any other country
before
are you saying that russia is still a
bigger enemy to us than china is today
the russian and the chinese intelligence
services
are as different as night and day
okay the chinese intelligence service
is and has been for decades
primarily interested in economic
espionage
they want to steal trade
secrets they want to steal technical
secrets
i mean you go back you know when you and
i were young
you couldn't get a ball bearing in china
you couldn't have get machine tools
since the 1960s chinese spies in america
have been desperately trying to steal
technological
knowledge technological expertise
trade secrets the russians
have a completely different outlook on
how they run
their espionage and intelligence
operations
i'm curious they have been interested
since the 1950s
and it's a continuous line it didn't end
when the cold war ended
in attacking our national security
agencies attacking the fbi attacking the
cia
in undermining our faith in democratic
institutions
and rubbing salt in the wounds of
american society
like race disinformation
has been one of their most powerful
weapons for example
did you ever hear that the cia killed
president kennedy
ever hear that one i've
read all the conspiracy theories on
kennedy and that's one of them yes
ever hear that the fbi assassinated
martin luther king yes ever hear that
aids was invented in an army germ
warfare laboratory in maryland
i have not heard that one now millions
of americans have
and believe it and you have been struck
by a kgb disinformation operation the
kgb set up a department of
disinformation in 1959
disinformation is a russian word
that's informative this information is
not
propaganda this information is a
deliberately disguised lie
meant to afflict and affect public
opinion
and public trust propaganda is one thing
america's number one that's you know
benign propaganda what's called black
propaganda or disinformation
is a deliberately disguised and
concealed lie that
undermines your sense of reality they
invented this
they're the world's greatest expert at
it
and look around you today disinformation
is damaging our democracy and that is a
triumph
of russian intelligence and a triumph of
the kgb
hood who runs russia vladimir putin
tim what is the outcome of all three so
if if and that's a very good way the way
you put it you said russia's economic
espionage so they simply want to be the
most powerful
other way around sorry china's economic
espionage china's economic espionage so
their outcome is more
let's create wealth and become the most
powerful economic uh
nation in the world et cetera et cetera
china's attack russia is attacking
national secret agencies uh whether it's
cia
fbi disinformation that's what they're
doing
and then usu kind of talked about the
angle of propaganda it's the greatest
country in the world you know american
german all this other stuff
what is the outcome of china what is the
outcome of russia and what is the
outcome of u.s
in your opinion i mean what is the
desired outcome
what is that what is the vision maybe a
better word is a vision what is the
vision what vision are they trying to
turn into reality you and i are old
enough
certainly i am to remember when china
was desperately poor and
uh in the 1970s nixon went to china as
you know
and uh the desired effect the desired
outcome as you say of nixon's
rapprochement with russia was to
divide russia and china there was still
a belief then
that russia and china were a global
monolith
of communism uh
trying to overthrow american democracy
well come to find out
through good intelligence produced by
the cia
russia and china have hated each other's
guts
since the end of world war ii they were
not a modeler
so it was imperative for the chinese
to try and create wealth
to try and lift their country up from
mass starvation and poverty
which existed well into the 1970s
and one way they do this is to send
tens of thousands of students and
businessmen
into the united states and a
surprisingly
large percentage of those people who are
told
by the chinese government
and by the chinese intelligences
you need to go
steal secrets get an education we'll pay
for it
but steal what you can learn what you
can
but take what you can and bring it back
home and you will be rewarded
the russian intelligence services now
remember
the us only set up an intelligence
service the cia 1947
the russians have been at this since
peter the great
okay they are very very good at what
they do and they play a long game
we're not that great we're americans you
know secrecy and deception
are not our strong suits they
are very good at secrecy and deception
they send
three kinds of agents one
is the sleeper agent who comes over
lives a normal life with a fake passport
and a fake identity pretending to be
anything but a russian spy
uh the fbi investigation
called ghost stories turned into a very
popular tv series the americans
so everybody knows how that works the
sleeper agent right
then there are people posing as
diplomats
or spies right they're not the second
secretary
of the so of the russian embassy in
washington they're not
you know uh the second in command
of the russian delegation of the united
nations they're spies working for
vladimir putin
and they are attempting to recruit
americans to work for them they have
been very very good at this
one of the stories i tell them the folly
in the glory is how
the russians and the soviets before them
cleaned america's clock
going back to the 1930s in the 30s and
the 40s and the 50s
they had spies at the manhattan project
and they stole the secret of the atomic
bomb
they had spies at the state department
they had spies at the pentagon at the
fbi
at the oss that's wartime intelligence
service that became the cia
in the 70s and 80s and 90s
they had the chief of soviet
counterintelligence at the cia
alder james was a spy for the kremlin
the head of the counter-intelligence
branch of the
fbi who was in charge of spying on the
soviets
robert hansen he was working from the
kremlin
from 1979 to 2001
they have penetrated our society and
they continue to do it today
the third kind of russian agent
is the agent of influence for example
in 1937 a united states congressman
named samuel dickstein represented the
lower east side here in new york where i
live
was chairman of the house immigration
and naturalization committee he walked
into the soviet embassy
sat down with the soviet ambassador
united states congressman
and said i can do things for you i can
sell you fake passports
for your spies i can hold hearings
against samuel against uh
stalin's enemies here in the united
states and he did that for three years
he was paid handsomely the congressman
was so greedy
that the kgb gave him a codename crook
he was an
agent of influence and that is the third
kind
of russian spy inside the united states
and that's someone
in a position of power and authority who
can affect
public opinion or public policy
that aids russia and i submit to you
and i'm not alone in saying this now so
buckle up
president trump's national security
advisor h.r mcmaster
the former head of the cia mike hayden
the former head of the cia who succeeded
him john brennan
and the multitude of former cia and fbi
officers
that i talked to for this book agree
that the president of the united states
today the man in the white house
is an agent of influence for russia
and that is a national security
nightmare
you're saying the president of president
trump is an agent of influence for
russia right now
this is the definition of an agent of
influence
which is the last one yes can i unpack
that for a second let me unpack that for
a second with you so
so so uh sleeper agent is the first one
fake passport fake identity you know
they just kind of go to this country and
start learning what's going on fake pass
for fake identity second one is the
diplomats
uh which are spies they recruit
americans that's the second kind
the third kind is the agent of influence
sam dickstein
kgb give him the code crook so the third
kind
sam dickstein is he
recruited by the kgb or they
identify him or he just leans towards
them what do you mean can you
unpack what the meaning of that is he
volunteered
he did it for the money you think trump
is doing that for money
i don't know what trump is doing okay
remember the definition of an agent of
influence a person
in position of authority or power
who can influence influence public
opinion
or policy in russia's favor
is there any question in your mind that
donald trump has done that
he has kissed putin's ring he is cow
towed to him
he has when russians put bounties
on american soldiers in afghanistan and
those soldiers die
trump does nothing about it he refuses
to push back on putin and as i said
the people i talked to for this book on
the record
and the people i've talked to for a
podcast i've done based on this book
called whirlwind
on the record former heads of the cia
former chiefs of
russian operations at the cia former fbi
counter intelligence agents
trump's own national security adviser
h.r mcmaster
they say that trump is aiding and
abetting putin
why why okay is the great mystery of our
time
yes why does he do it why does he bend
his knee to poop
i raise the question of why and i have
several theories about it
i'd love to hear it a few days ago my
old newspaper the new york times
published details from trump's tax
returns
you read that story i did all of it
trump
owes percy's personally on the hook
okay hundreds of millions of dollars
the grand total is 421 million he is on
the hook for about three quarters that
personally not the trump organization to
whom does he owe that money
and who will help him pay it back now
you know about security clearances right
you're ex-military i do you know
something about the work how the world
works
there's levels to it what is the number
one red flag for somebody
who's getting a security clearance
financial challenges financial
difficulties
okay the reason for it is motivation
meaning you will be desperate to make a
deal that may be
worse than that look the russian
intelligence services are very good at
penetrating financial institutions
okay they have a very close and very
illicit
set of relationships with deutsche bank
the german bank that loaned hundreds of
millions of dollars to donald trump
after his sixth bankruptcy when no one
else would touch him
okay they know
who donald trump holds that money to and
they can hold this over
his head compromising information
compromise
as they would put it so that's one
theory of the case
there's another theory of the case a
little less scary
perhaps an agent of influence what does
he do
he's not stealing secrets he's using his
influence to affect public opinion and
public policy
by the way this is not my definition
this is the definition
in the american counterintelligence
handbook
putin has flattered him putin has given
him political support
openly and covertly given trump's
vanity his ego maybe all
putin has to do is influence him
and win influence in return that is
personally my theory of the case
because i don't have knowledge of who
trump owes that money to
but he doesn't know it to the federal
credit union i'll tell you that
so we got two of them so far so the
first one is the theory is finance out
of the 400 million dollars give or take
421.
three quarters is his own debt deutsche
bank who's going to help him out here
is there a finance possibly linked to
russia no one knows second one is putin
flattered him
he's giving him love back so maybe
that's the way that that's taking place
is there any other ones that you have
donald trump first went to moscow in
1987.
he had a czech wife to whom he was
unfaithful and a pronounced taste for
slavic women
none of that matters he was trying to
build a luxury hotel
in partnership with the soviet
government
across red square from the kremlin if
the kgb didn't put his target
a target on his back at that moment
we got a bridge here in brooklyn that
connects with manhattan would you like
to buy it
it would have been criminally negligent
of the kgb not to target donald trump
at that point and we won't know the
answer to the question of
why trump behaves this way until the cia
recruits
the guy in the russian intelligence
service who
has seen a thick file that says d trump
on the cover but i guarantee you that
file exists
and that file has existed since 1987.
okay so so that's a that's a different
angle he went there in 87
so wanted to build a hotel in
partnership with soviet government
it's uh behooves the kgb model
of a regime to hold them accountable
without getting anything in return
i can see that part okay is there any
other ones that you have
outside of those three okay
so that hotel that luxury hotel in
moscow
trump was still trying to build it in
2015 and 2016 when he was running for
president
he was going to make a lot of money off
that hotel he was looking at 300 million
dollars
which is about the sum of money
that he's personally liable for on debts
that are coming
due to three years from now his uh
business associate
in this a convicted felon named felix
sater
who happened to be in partnership
business partnership
with a trump organization dangled
a 50 million dollar penthouse at the top
of this hotel
in front of poo throw it in deal
sweetener
donald trump said at the time he was
running for president that he had no
business interest
in russia but he did a major business
interest
that if it had gone through and he
didn't become
president which looked like a pretty
good bet
four years ago right it would heal him
financially
this deal and he was asked about it do
you have any business interests in
russia he was asked about on the
campaign trail
and he said no i have no business
interest in russia
why is he lying i don't have an answer
to that
is it because he lies for sport because
he likes to engage in what he calls
truthful hyperbole or did he have
something to hide
these are questions that i explore in
the last chapters of this book
and they need to be answered now you'll
recall
that in the spring of 2017
donald trump fired the fbi director jim
comey
and he said on tv with lester holt on
nbc news
that he'd fired him because the fbi was
investigating
the connections between team trump and
team putin
in the 2016 campaign this set off a
rather large red flag
at fbi headquarters the bureau the fbi
had just been decapitated
why trump told them why it was because
of the russia investigation
so at that time it took about 12 days
the time between
comey's firing and the appointment of
robert mueller's
special counsel with a very limited
brief
to look into connections between team
trump and team putin
mueller never looked at his financials
at fbi headquarters
the senior counterintelligence agent who
was going to run this case
said it was like those 12 days were like
the cuban missile crisis
the difference was that the cuban
missile crisis lasted 13 days
and it had a happy ending because
the fbi set out can you imagine how hard
this was
to mount a counter-intelligence
investigation of the president of the
united states
to determine the answer to the questions
i just raised why
why did he behave this way with putin
why did he fire the fbi director to kill
the russia investigation
that investigation never happened it was
strangled in its crib
at the highest levels of the trump
justice department
and that is why we do not know the
answer to these questions
that investigation never happened it
vanished into thin air
we've covered a lot so far right now
so you said the first one which is 421
million dollars in debt three quarters
of it is personal deutsche bank great
that's the first theory second one is
putin flattered him
third one is his trip to 1987 to moscow
to
build a hotel with soviet union team up
with them and they have to hold them
accountable they're not going to let
them go and just not hold them hostage
because the model was you better
you know do something there's got to be
something in it for us the fourth one is
felix sater
50 million dollar penthouse that was
offered and felix was a former felon
and then the last one you just discussed
right now with mueller
which there wasn't a happy ending after
12 days so i have this question for you
i have this question for you so for me
i'm middle eastern i don't know i don't
know if you've done a lot of business
with middle easterns middle easterners
don't trust anybody
you know they're skeptical they're
skeptical with everybody and anybody
they don't trust their kids their family
their friends
i would say that that's not unique to
uh the middle eastern mind i i've spent
a lot of time in afghanistan
i'd like to take credit for tourism in
afghanistan i'd like us to own it
that we have that identity okay it makes
it
[Laughter]
so you know for for for for for us you
know the painting behind me it's got two
books on the
on the table that they're debating and
all these folks that are debating there
uh one is uh atlas shrugged the other
one is communist manifesto and there one
is saying one is right the other one who
says the other one is right they're
just debating back and forth that's the
shaw in the middle by the way with
milton friedman mlk
jfk lincoln einstein the two guys in the
back you don't see is me tupac and senna
anyways
so for me that's a great painting well
thank you i have looked at that's
thank you so for me i like to hear from
both sides and i like to bring people
here
from both sides to kind of here if we
want to do a debate on capitalism i'll
bring richard wolff
and we'll talk for 90 minutes i'll bring
slavoy g-jek to talk about communism and
i'll bring somebody on the capitalist
side let's just kind of talk about it
and see what's out there
what do you say to the recent report
that came 24 hours ago
intelligence official urged trump spy
chief not to disclose unverified russian
claims about clinton's
officials at cia nsa and officer office
of director national uh
intelligence warned disclosure to
congress would give credibility to
kremlin back
material and here's a statement that was
made on september 7th
by graham asking a question to comey
you don't remember getting an
investigative investigatory
lead from the intelligence community
september 7 2016. us intelligence
officials forwarded an investigative
referrals to james comey
and his team regarding clinton's
approval of a plan
about trump as a means of distraction
graham asks comey wednesday comey says
new information that hillary clinton
drummed up russia controversy to vilify
trump doesn't ring a bell
doesn't ring a bell and then it
continues a little bit more saying what
do you mean it doesn't ring a bell i
don't remember so
the reason why i bring this up the
reason why i bring this up and then i'll
turn it over to you can go well i'll
listen to you
i bring this up because i had an fbi
agent on the other day probably a month
and a half
ago and he came across as somebody that
wasn't too
uh uh he was a little bit embarrassed
about talking about being an fbi jail
he's the guy that took mcdonald's down i
don't know if you remember when mcdonald
had that whole monopoly scandal with 24
million dollars where
the guy was holding on to the monopoly
thing and fbi eventually got a
anyway so he was when the fbi agents
that did that america doesn't trust fbi
today
america doesn't trust comey today
america doesn't trust cia today
how does somebody like comey who's good
friends with clinton family saying
it doesn't ring a bell so i totally hear
what you're saying on this side but
what do you say to the people that are
saying i don't trust comey i'm
here because that's a lot to unpack
please all right
let's talk about the first part of what
you said
was it is that the guy who trump
appointed very recently be the director
of national intelligence
he's a congressman named john ratcliffe
and
john ratcliff knows about as much about
intelligence as i know about theoretical
astrophysics
which is to say not a lot trump put
him there to control the flow of
intelligence
about what russia is doing to us right
now my friend
from congress and from the american
people
john ratcliffe two days ago
took a piece of russian disinformation
specifically the idea that hillary
clinton
monkey wrenched the 2016 election
and fed it uncorroborated
worse than uncorroborated identified
has russian disinformation had a big
like do not believe
sticker stamped on it by the cia and the
fbi
and he fed it into the public
consciousness
why to make us believe that there are no
facts
and there is no truth let me take you
back
do you remember when trump and putin
were in helsinki at a press conference
in july 2018.
i do both stand there trump and putin
and a reporter ask them both
so there's been a unanimous conclusion
by all the american intelligence
services there's 17 of them by the way
that russia tried to monkey wrench
the 2016 election to help elect trump
and defeat hillary clinton
and donald trump says well you know my
director of national intelligence
same position i just told you about but
this guy knew about intelligence
my director of national intelligence
tells me
that everybody in the united states
intelligence community
thinks it's russia on the one hand
on the other hand i got putin here and
he tells me it wasn't russia
and i say i don't see any reason why it
should be russia
so he's believing putin's denial over
the
mountain of evidence collected by his
intelligence services
and then putin said something equally
important nobody remembers this
putin says well
i'm translating here but i'll do it in a
russian accent
well as to who can be believed
and who cannot be believed no one can be
believed
there is no truth there are no facts
that is the pointed end of the spirit
of russian political warfare and our
president of the united states
carries that spear my friend there are
no facts and there is no truth
but that can be said about both sides
towards him i mean you know we can say
that
besides me my friend that's but that's
talking about a very specific question
do you think america is trying to
overthrow the russians
government right now no right
so that's one side the other side is do
you think russia is trying to screw with
american democracy
yes ah there you're both sides
well what does that have to do with uh
so you're saying the fact that trump
said uh if he's saying that i believe
him like like that
that okay i get that and and look i'm
not going to say leaving
the leader of russia who is running this
intelligence operation and is running it
right now over the entire
power of american intelligence
he's the one trashing the fbi yeah he's
the one trashing the cia what they
deserve he's the one trashing american
diplomats abroad
calling them human skunk
he's a wrecking ball he's doing the
russians work
for them in the spear in the sphere
of national security that's bad news my
friend so i got a question then i got i
got a question for you and and
i sincerely listen if if you say i
absolutely
agree or disagree with what you're
saying trash my
statement do i'm not going to take your
person because i'm trying to get
i'm trying to see both sides of the
argument here just tell me you're
absolutely wrong so
so say for for example you know for me
i sit there and um you know how you said
there is a
potential of motive so who's he thinking
the deutsche bank the 300 million
dollars say three quarters of it is
personal debt
who's going to help them pay that off
and you know sometime when you recruit
somebody in the military if you have too
much there they're worried about you
because if somebody from the enemy
officer you got to secure of course all
this stuff i remember all of this
we had a guy that came in the only way
they let the guy join the army was he
had to pay off his 45
dollars of debt before he went in
because tremen was concerned that that
could be used as a
you know way to persuade him to be
willing to share information which i get
right i totally understand that part i
get that but to me
you know like let me give you from the
innocence standpoint
this guy had a great life before
becoming a president you know
you have to realize he's got an
incredible life he
whether you like the way he lives his
personal life stormy daniels karen
mcdougall i mean if you think that never
happened you're a fool
whether you think you know the lavish
lifestyle he lived
large not driving women all this stuff
okay
you know is he a you know cocky
you know i'm the greatest that kind of a
mindset when he walks into the room i'm
the person that walks into the room he
pushes the other prime ministers out
because i'm here
i don't think anybody disagrees because
we see that on tape but
you're worth say at the lowest 2.7
billion dollars and he said he was 10
billion to be higher on the forbes list
let's just say he did that to be
recognized higher but let's just say
he's worth a couple billion dollars
and he's not but but you're saying he's
done
your own time story did you read i did
if you're somebody that wants
credibility you have to also realize
that
that new york times story is given to us
by a
person that leaked information that's
anonymous that we don't really know to
see the papers because it's illegal
because it could be a former irs
employee
or existing irs employee so we cannot
also naively just choose to believe it
because we want to believe it we have to
say
if it is not it is it's an if it is not
and it is
a big difference you're a journalist
hang on here yeah
let's posit sure that the new york times
didn't make up
the biggest story of the year okay i
worked for the new york times for 16
years
they probably have his tax returns okay
give me that much i don't disagree that
they don't have what i'm saying is the
fact that we haven't seen everything for
you and i to jump to conclusions that
everything's true
of course not sure so
why didn't donald trump pay taxes
for 10 out of the last 15 years before
he became prison
because he lost tens of millions of
dollars hand over fists
he's a terrible businessman in
depreciation
he's had six bankruptcies
he built an image of himself on the
apprentice
an image of an incredible brilliant
billionaire businessman
and he sold that image to tens of
millions of people across the united
states
you've got to understand this i'm a new
yorker
i've known this guy since the 70s he's a
con man
he's a grifter he's a hustler
and he's conned the people in the united
states
for a long time now and the con the long
con
is going to be over what's going to
happen to him
when he loses the invisibility cloak of
presidential power
manhattan d.a right across the river is
going after the financials of the trump
organization
the manhattan d.a right across the river
is going to see those tax returns
i'll make you a bet
dinner at your favorite restaurant on
your favorite restaurant
okay in new york no i love i love new
york
me anywhere you want to go all right
let's assume that the restaurants will
be back open again a year
we're not going to know we'll be back
we're not going to know how this bet
comes out
sure i will bet you
dinner at the best restaurant in new
york time
that when donald trump loses the
invisibility cloak
of presidential power on january 20th
mm-hmm he will be the target of multiple
criminal investigations here in new york
and he's going down so
so is the bet the fact that he'll be
targeted or he's going to go down
because i do agree he'll be targeted but
the bet is on going down
all right let's refine the bet let's
refine the bet
it's him going down because i know i'm
not saying he's going to do the
you know being an orange jumpsuit in two
years
i'm gonna say he's gonna be under
criminal indictment in new york
i i think he will be i i wouldn't bet
that because i agree he would you're not
gonna take my butt
no because i know he's going to be
because there are a lot of people in the
city of new york that
hate this
i think it's bigger than that though i
think you have to realize when when
when uh when emotions gets involved in
politics people show their true colors
and
you know when you see two competitors
fighting and there is a deeper emotion
involved i mean people should like when
one time i remember one time
oscar de la hoya was fighting i don't
know who he was fighting he was fighting
this one guy
the guy started talking about his wife
and de la hoya finally got up and he
said
now you crossed the line you crossed the
line you say something about my wife
it's over
what was the guy's name can you find out
which boxer told something about i
remember exactly
you know what i'm talking about it was a
showman he started saying stuff to his
wife he says
and in spanish you told him you come
after my family you come after my
heritage you come after my wife it's
over
money before you were born with a great
boxer named jersey joe walcott
his opponent question is masculinity
walcott hit him so hard that he
died all right i wouldn't be surprised
because
this is not this is not a battle that's
going to be fought under the rules of
the martini
the queensbury my friend this is a
battle
this is not warfare this is not a cage
match on wwe
okay this is the law and the law
is coming for this man but but but let
me go a little deeper with you let me
ask my question let me ask my question
and then
attack the question okay let me ask the
question we're having a good time here
so so so again you're worth billions
okay a legend let's say he is let's say
he is
worth billions okay you have the nice
penthouse you have all these buildings
with your name on them yeah you've had
six bankruptcies you know as a business
person if you're in the world of
business
i've been a lot of billionaires and one
thing billionaires have in common the
average billion has three bankruptcy
that's just the number out there so it's
very common
amongst billionaires because some things
just don't work out that's very
normal it's it's uh uh it's it's like in
the military if you're in the military
for 20 years and you've been married to
the for
to the same woman for 20 years you're
saying because it doesn't happen often
the other day i interviewed we had all
right we'll stipulate that donald trump
is not a saint go on
yeah okay so there we go but the point
i'm trying to make to you is this guy's
a billionaire
he parties he goes to all the shows they
love him he's great he's always on tv
letterman leno what do they like him or
not they know he brings eyeballs
wrote a book ordered a deal he's got a
show apprentice 15 seasons got money
his kids are doing okay he's all over
the place on tv gets invited to all the
big parties has the golf course has
mar-a-lago
why the hell would you run for office
and ruin your life
i mean what is the motive the answer is
theory i don't have i'll give you all
the theories if you want to go through
the theories but if your theory is
okay tell me
i don't think he thought he was gonna
win okay
i thought he thought it would be good
for the brand
and he needed to protect the brand
because he was up to his
keister in debt that's why
why do you like him so much because i
love america
i'm an immigrant too
my mother ran from the nazis my father
ran from the nazis my father
met my mother on a blind date here in
new york in 1953 they were married three
weeks later fort hood
wow for the biggest military base in
america and texas
they were married for 50 years wow
uh i love american democracy
i think it's the greatest system of
government ever invented or as winston
churchill said
democracy is the worst system of
government except for all the others
our democracy is in trouble my friend
it's under attack it's under attack by
the russians
and it's under attack by the president
of the united states
we're gonna have an election
in less than five weeks after we're
talking
33 days the president says he's not
going to accept
the outcome of the election if he loses
he said that right
well hillary said biden shouldn't either
for for a full intensive purposes
i'm talking about the president of the
united states i'm talking about hillary
the the face of the democratic party
clinton is not the issue here my friend
i'm i'm trying to have some problems
here because timothy donald trump is the
issue
okay the president of the united states
said
in the debate the other day yeah i don't
care
if i don't win it's a fraud
yeah and i'm not leaving okay
you've lived and worked in countries
that are not functioning democracies
absolutely so have i
democracy is a very fragile thing it's
an experiment
and if that happens the guy loses and he
says it's a fraud i'm not leaving
our 240-year 243-year
experiment a democracy
is in deep deep trouble i don't want to
see that happen
so who do you think will be better for
the job bite nor trump
i'm going to vote for biden i'm not
happy about it
but i'm going to vote for biden because
i think trump all right
let me tell you something so for this
book
and i'm trying to get people interested
in here the folly in the glory
and for this podcast that i just dropped
called whirlwind which is based on the
book nice
i interviewed general michael hayden
you remember mike hayden general michael
hayden
head of the national security agency
under president george w
bush head of the cia under george w
bush patriot
deeply conservative four-star general
so so we talked and i asked him just
what you're asking me
i said what do you think is going to
happen because you know the ci is
supposed to be good at predicting things
right
here's what general hayden said
four-star general american patriot
he said if donald trump wins this
election american democracy
is over we'll stop
uh will you were you more of a sanders
fan or a biden fan
me yeah kinda like elizabeth warren
oh you liked elizabeth warren
interesting
she reminded me of my mother my mother
was a history professor
got it uh you know came here without
a diamond or pocket uh
lifted herself up by her bootstraps so
you know i didn't agree by
any means with everything elizabeth
warren said
but i love i i like the fact that she
was a self-made woman
and she's smart now
you don't see her around much these days
no you don't
but i'm surprised but i like elizabeth
warren yeah
who in your opinion is the greatest
president greatest statesman we've ever
had
greatest president greatest greatest
statesman give me both they could be
separate because statements could not
necessarily be a president
statesman roosevelt president eisenhower
i think that's fair that you're saying
that because you know
what that does to the audience
i i think that's where you're saying
that now look there's a lot of things
that we're talking about that you and i
may not
agree on but i can respect your approach
and
why you believe in the things that you
do let me ask you this last question
here i don't know why i think eisenhower
was
the greatest president i'd be i'm very
curious
five-star general yep knew a thing or
two about
you know how power works ran the d-day
invasion
understood war and conflict
after he settled the korean war which he
did in the first
weeks of his presidency not a single
american soldier
died of shot and shell in combat under
president eisenhower
because he knew how to wage peace
that's why she also got you got to tell
a little bit more than that because
the enemy was scared shitless of the guy
they they they
he ran the d-day invasion that's what
i'm saying to you meaning like they're
there
listen the russians weren't scared and
they respected him
i i can't say i i i i think he had both
of them though i think there's a part of
it where you have respect and there's a
little bit of fear there's nothing wrong
with having a little bit of fear for a
leader
but i would say yes they probably had a
little bit of both but but here's a
question for you
you've heard the same before uh
enemy of an enemy is a friend right so a
friend of an enemy could be an enemy
so what do you say with the fact that
both
iran and china would prefer a biden
presidency over trump so would the
germans the french
the english all our allies
have you seen the polling on this you
think boris wants uh biden over trump
i'm talking about the people
iranian government not even the people
the people uh uh
they don't have a say in the matter
chinese and
government and the iranian government
they kind of do though if you think
about it what i'm asking you is
why do you think iran the leaders of
iran and the leaders of china
hate trump and they love biden why would
they prefer biden presidency right
it's a sincere question you are
stating that the leaders of iran and
china love
bible i don't see the basis for that
statement
i see what i see around the world
and i've studied this okay i've spent a
lifetime studying this
our power as a country it's not based on
nuclear weapons
it's not on
stealth aircraft
our strength as a nation is the image
that we project in the world
everyone who has studied this question
and i mean everyone
right left center liberal conservative
see what is happening to the image of
the united states in the world
the way in which we project our power by
saying
we are a shining city on a hill
we're not today we have handled
the coronavirus crisis worse than
anybody in the world
they have less than five percent of the
world's population we have a quarter of
the deaths
our image as a country has been damaged
by this president and i fear for our
republic
i love this country this is why i wrote
this book to find
the following and the glory to make
people understand
that we are at war with russia that war
is fought with political warfare
we won the 20th century we helped bring
down the soviet union the evil empire
they are winning the 21st century
and that is a danger mortal danger
to the united states of america people
need to know this
there's a lot to be said with what
you're saying uh
the audience can make up make up their
mind for themselves uh for me
uh i really worry about china way more
than i worry about russia and i know
you know the difference between russia
and china the way i break it down is the
following
russia will come to you and tell you
we're powerful if you mess with us we'll
kill you
that's russia will come to you and china
will say
uh we respect you you're so great and
take every information out of your house
and leave
there's a big difference between i'm
talking about the people i'm talking
about the government i'm not talking
about the people so
i i i don't i don't disagree with you on
the fact that you can never take russia
lightly because russia's
motivation is to be the most powerful
regime in the world power power
but i don't think china's right behind
them i think those two are very close to
each other
i am not an expert on china yeah full
stop
i am an expert on this war between
america and russia
fair enough the tools that they are
using are not the weapons of war
they are disinformation sabotage
subversion
and they'll those are the weapons of the
weak
this is asymmetrical warfare
and they are cleaning our clock my
friend they are hurting us
and the president united states has done
nothing
to prevent it and he is actively
aiding and abetting them right now don't
take my word for it
take the words of his national security
adviser
general h.r mcmaster he uttered those
words today
trump is aiding and abetting putin
this is an emergency i want people to
read
this book to understand how that
emergency came to pass
here's what we're gonna do okay we're
gonna put the link to your book below
are you more on twitter or more on
instagram which one are you more active
on
oh twitter yeah instagram i'm too old
for instagram listen i i thought you
were hip i'm i give you the credit
with the flowers you got in the back i
fully qualified you as a hip uh
you know a person from the 70s so we're
going to put the link to your book below
the foliage the glory the folly of the
glory and then also we're going to put
the link to your twitter so if anybody
wants to send you a message directly as
well they can do that
even better the podcast called whirlwind
it's on apple podcasts on radio.com
it's really good if i do say so myself
it's the number one new and noteworthy
podcast on apple podcast today
check it out it's extremely entertaining
tim if you send us that interview
with the general that you did we'll put
that at the bottom for people to be able
to go listen to it
so if you just send us the link the team
will put it below they'll be able to
listen to it as well
i gotta talk to my producer about that
okay that sounds good
if you if you're producer-proof you
sounds like you're a producer you're
like an italian family let me talk to
the people see what i can do
yeah i had to talk to the couple
by the way you get you got a way of
doing accents i saw a couple of your
talks you did a couple good accents so
you got a gift there as well but
uh in closing uh tim thank you so much
for being a guest on valuetainment i
really enjoyed it i appreciate you
sharing your perspective with us
and hopefully we still have to have a
bet so how about we make the bet on the
presidency are you confident enough to
make it biden trump
i'm willing to take any side just to
have some kind of a bet with your dinner
because
what's the over under 115 minus 115
meaning biden's in favor
in favor right now of winning vegas
what is it in vegas vegas has him you
bet a hundred it's uh you win 85.
you got to bet 115 to win 100.
i'll take that so do you want to do
dinner you take biden i take trump if
biden wins
dinner's on me if trump wins dinner's on
you you got a bet
bet new york favorite restaurant we go
to it i'm good with that
yeah better than 150 so it's all good
you tell me where you want to go i'll
treat you i've enjoyed the conversation
a lot tim
once again thank you so much for your
time take care bye-bye all right
so do you agree with him do you agree
with what he had to say comment below
yes no maybe i don't know he made some
points for himself but you could tell
there was emotions behind there as well
i did definitely enjoy uh speaking with
him again if you haven't gotten the book
we'll put the link below for you to go
out there and get it but i got two other
interviews i want you to watch if you
enjoyed this one
i have one interview i did with a former
28th year i believe cia agent jonah
mendes who
she was a chief disguise officer what
she did for longest time if you've never
watched this interview i did it right
outside the white house
and you almost see the view divide white
house if you've never seen this click
over here
if you want to see the interview i did
with the uh uh
john perkins who worked with different
countries going negotiating
and he was an economic hitman very
interesting story
click over here to watch it and if
you've not subscribed to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye